25 percent of the migrants dropped off
at a shelter tested positive for covet
according to reports the director says
that was just in the first group
dropped off the actual number may go
higher it's happening in harlingen texas
want to bring in the mayor chris boswell
sir good morning to you white house
doesn't say it's a crisis
they're asking for volunteers to help if
it's not about if it's not a crisis why
do you need volunteers and how would you
characterize it mayor
well good morning thank you for having
me on it's certainly a
it certainly can turn into a
humanitarian crisis we've seen this
before
a few years ago and when the
unaccompanied minors in particular
come to our communities
they don't have any place to go we
although we have shelters that have been
operating in our communities
including harlingen for a number of
years these traditional shelters
operate well and safely for the
unaccompanied miners
when there's some such an influx uh it
it
really can be a dangerous situation
what's the impact on your
town i think that local government is
the actual it's actually the hardest
government
that's where you actually really have to
do things for people so what's the
impact for you
well i mean these are decisions made by
the by the federal government and should
be
handled by the federal government but
they turn into
problems for local governments because
about three weeks ago the border patrol
told us
uh in mcallen brownsville and harlingen
that they would be
uh releasing primarily families into our
communities
and they come here to not this is not
the end point this is not their final
destination
they're being released into brownsville
mcallen harlingen because we have
airports and bus stations
we also have charity facilities and so
when those charity facilities can't
accommodate them then
we have to provide additional
accommodations for them and so we have
our city
council has opened up
a uh one of our one of our facilities a
community center
in case our local charity loads and
fishes needs
that additional space and so that
becomes a burden and expense on the
local governments and
our local governments really need to
have help from the federal government
to respond to the release of
these immigrants into our communities
mayor it is march 9th
did you see this coming
well obviously you know with the
election there were uh uh
the the idea that that there would be a
change in policy we knew that there
would be a change in policy we also knew
that there were
large numbers of uh immigrants
camped in matamoros uh waiting to be
to enter uh the united states to seek
asylum
and so once the policy changed then sure
i mean they're gonna cut their
their they're going to move across and
then try to find their final
destinations
one of the things about this is not just
a border issue this is a
an issue for everyone because uh
these folks are not as i said this is
not their final destination along the
border
let me just squeeze excuse me one more
precise question jen saki on msnbc
said 90 minutes ago she said we are here
in this circumstance
because we are humane was the last
administration
inhumane
well you know there many of us believe
that
it's not humane to have young
children travel uh from central america
to
the border uh and that is not uh
that that is fraught with the potential
problems of trafficking and uh
the difficulties in in traveling so far
for such a long period of time
and i think there's you know by there's
been in the past
bipartisan concerns about that being a
humanitarian problem
all right mr mayor thank you so much for
being with us today and good luck to you
down there on the border
thank you sir thank you